I want us to remember why it is that we
use tools like this like Venn diagrams
right we use Venn diagrams when we've
got a situation and there are groups or
categories that overlap in some way okay
does that make sense we've got groups or
categories and there are people who sit
in both groups or in both categories so
Venn diagrams are really good at
representing that information but
they're not always the perfect tool
right you've got the toolbox you don't
use the hammer for everything you like
use the hammer for this particular kind
of situation you use the screwdriver for
something else or for something else and
this question here how many stage four
students have siblings it feels like it
should be a Venn diagram question right
because I can say there are some
categories there's some overlap my
question to you is suppose we break this
down a little bit further right within
stage four probably the two most obvious
groups would be if I wanted to sort of
slice this up a little you're 17 you're
8 you're seven you're right they're both
can stage four so let's just jot that
down for a second here are two
categories and then when I look at the
rest of the question the other glaring
category is people who have siblings and
I guess the complement what would be the
complement of that group remember that
word what's compliment bad someone
together hey very good if you don't have
siblings
you are only child so you're one of
these two so let's say have siblings or
an only child right by the way just out
of sheer curiosity how many people
aren't only taught in this room ends up
so I'm counting one two three four five
five okay thank you here's that so let's
just suppose right we've got this kind
of breakdown of people who are only
children people who have siblings and
then we have the seven eight breakdown
here's my question to you what would the
Venn diagram look like for these groups
for these categories okay now you don't
have to draw this and I'll tell you why
in a second
but let's just imagine if I tried I'm
gonna do my best here I think it's good
that way here we go okay I've got four
circles okay I've got four circles
does that look confusing to you it looks
uvision to me partly because my circles
are not very well drawed okay but also
there's a bigger problem okay I want you
to have a look at this if
I call the c7 and he ate and then
siblings and only child
okay do you notice on this diagram there
are lots of sections of this diagram
that a kind of pointless everything goes
right can someone give me an example of
an area that I don't actually want on
this header you can't have a person
who's in the sibling circle and also in
the only child circles so the overlap
between those two circles I think it's
looking carefully and my bad circles I
think it's this region here I think this
is the one that haters talking about
right
simply exactly child that that area is
clearly gonna be empty right there's
another area that's kind of pointless
too what is it oh you know go ahead you
can use other shapes in fact vendors do
not have to be circles we'll come to
that in a second though in terms of like
what alternatives could you do that
would be simpler and one of reasons
where you see up circles is because
they're the simplest but Jessica I know
you're like desperate to say something
what are you seeing on the diagram okay
so barring weird confusing things I
don't think a student can be in two
grades simultaneously do you agree okay
so that means these 7/8 circles here
year 8 circles here so I think it's this
spot in here that's gonna be empty do
you agree right now you're like oh there
are all of these regions in my diagram
they're not going to need because
they're impossible but then there are
other ones which are also a bit silly
right like how about this spot here what
what does this spot represent so year 7
who apparently is not an only child and
also has no siblings so they're like
that's what kind of a person is that is
that even possible right and yeah you're
starting to realize oh there are lots of
regions in here that are kind of
pointless it's like I am I'm a sibling
but I'm not you seven or eight but
somehow I turned up in a stage four I
was in the wrong room at the wrong time
right so you've got all of these really
silly areas on here the Venn diagram is
not that helpful okay
now the issue here is that these um
these categories many of them are
mutually exclusive do you remember that
phrase from mrs. Lee's yesterday so
you can't be in you 17 year rate if
you're in u7 you're excluded from being
in your 8 if you're in your aunt you're
excluded from being in 7 so they
mutually exclude each other so rather
than have overlapping circles I should
have probably had year 7 and then year 8
and it's kind of the same thing for
siblings and only child's right you
can't be both so here's one circle and
he's the ah the one which is separate
but even so we still have this problem
of these red regions which are kinda
pointless right you're like I don't need
these on my diagram they're Jack's just
extra fluff okay so here's how we're
going to represent it instead remember I
asked you to leave a spot for that
subheading there's something I'd like
you to make is two-way tables two-way
tables now what we want to do is take
this same set of information and
represent it in the simplest way
possible
use 7 & 8 we're gonna make these the
rows of our table and siblings / only
children we're going to make them their
columns so go ahead and draw something
that looks roughly like this you're
gonna need to have a situation that
looks so like that yeah so this is a
table which is much simpler for a
situation like this it takes a bit of
thinking to recognize oh look at my
situation should I use a Venn diagram
should they use something else as we get
more familiar with these situations
you'll get better at picking which one
is which okay so let's just put in some
information into this I might say year 7
is here and year 8 is here and
importantly unlike in the Venn diagram
you can see these two columns they don't
overlap because they're not meant to do
they are mutually exclusive right and
then I can say have siblings and only
child okay now in this room I'm actually
just going to make up some numbers right
now because I'm on the basis of you guys
five of you said you were the only child
and I guess that means roughly mmm 5 out
of I'm gonna call 25 just to make the
numbers
simple so let's say 20% 20% of year rate
are going to be only children now happen
to know there's roughly 300 students in
the in the grade so I think that would
make this 60 and 240 someone can
double-check those numbers for me so if
I knew that there were 300 people in
your main and roughly 20% have no
siblings and the other people have
siblings then these might be my numbers
do you think your sevens similar
different reasonable guess to say it's
similar so let's have some sort of
similar numbers here I think you're 7
actually is you something smaller how
it's bigger ok let's make this bigger to
compensate let's let's make this like
230 more so I'm at I've got out to 330
then at least on my numbers anyway 200
and mmm 73 yes 73 I'm working really
hard for made-up numbers ok say yeah
here you go
now look at this situation right just
compare that table to my like Olympic
logo overlapping circles Venn diagrams
for a situation like this a table has no
wasted information it's all much simpler
and I can read really quickly you can
tell me how many you rate since there
are instantly just add up the numbers
and in fact sometimes you'll see a
number down the bottom which ends up
showing the total 330 I could ask you
for example if I picked out a random
stage for student a random stage for
student what's the chance that they have
siblings I'm gonna go out for a second
if I picked out a random stage for Sue
one of these students what would be the
chance that they have siblings there's a
number I need to calculate which I
haven't calculated yet five hundred and
five hundred and thirteen do that right
yeah over six hundred and thirty so that
probability of having siblings
would be my favorable outcomes of which
we just found 513 of them bless you / my
total sample space and I don't think 513
to pick up prime number no wait that's
divisible by three um there's someone
tell me that is divided by three I don't
know what is divided by three
it'll be seventy are you've already
eaten what 57 out of 70 oh you divided
by nine well that was that was handy I
didn't mean to do that
57 out of 70 there we go no it's fine
that's okay I was just marveling and how
I coincident Lee came up with random
numbers that simplified nicely okay so
there we go and if we wanted we could do
the same thing for only children that's
a hundred and seventeen you could
calculate that as well if you liked okay